a desperate people know nothing of mercy
[Applause]
[Music]
for years we the people had suffered the
poverty of men to fed to starve to rest
at air but no more
la république I've endured years of war
and failed military campaigns a playful
power by Kings who cared more for their
legacy than their people with the nation
deeply in debt the nobility carried on
with the lavish lifestyles ignoring our
struggles and levying taxes upon us to
shoulder the load for reforms we starved
in the streets tossed aside like a rats
no longer would we be left to die
we formed a National Assembly for the
Third Estate our first step in the fight
for independence yes
we never could have known the dangers
that lie waiting the National Assembly
vowed for life we were willing to do
what was needed violently if necessary
surged unstoppable the taste of freedom
and liberty fell upon each of our lips
[Music]
when la bestia fell we grew hungrier not
some thread of brain but for justice
even his highness wasn't safe from our
reach
1400 he dismissed our frets let him try
to ignore us now
after ordering the death of the king
one month Oersted for control he claimed
to represent the people against the
monarchy but was far more dangerous than
any King maximilien de Robespierre the
slightest suspicion of
counter-revolution was met with death
mere rumors and speculation so many of
us meet I will end families torn apart
by hobus peers reign a reign of terror
hundreds of thousands dead straight son
that with blood but the reign of terror
would not last or the spear knew he was
to meet the very end he had boat upon so
many while fighting his arrest he tried
to make his escape but he was
unsuccessful a bullet to the Joe to
remind him of his failure
[Music]
a desperate people know nothing of mercy
[Applause]
this is the history you know behind the
bloodshed alekhya team
a different secret revolution awaited
its story burning to be told make
history Assassin's Creed unity pre-order
now for 2 bonus offers the guillotines
spend a win game get a chance to win
prizes every Friday and the explosive
chemical revolution mission pre-order
now available October 28th